Speaker 1: OK, if you want to get a sense of how
long this election fraud stuff is going to be
going on, Donald Trump just sent a letter to the
Georgia secretary of state, Brad Raffensperger,
demanding that he be declared the winner of
Georgia. Trump demanding that Trump be declared
the winner of Georgia. Don't check your calendar.
This isn't a repeat. It really is mid-September of
twenty twenty one. It's not November of twenty
twenty. It's not December of twenty twenty.
It's it's almost October of twenty twenty one.
And Donald Trump is demanding that he be given the
state of Georgia in the November of twenty twenty
election. Donald Trump sent this letter on Friday.
I fully expected when I saw this headline
I thought this must be four months ago.
It must have just resurfaced
like it can't be from now.
But indeed it is. The letter is dated September
17. Twenty twenty one. The letter says,
Dear Secretary Raffensperger, large scale voter
fraud cap, random capitalization. I still don't
understand it. His followers do it to large scale.
Voter fraud continues to be reported in Georgia.
Enclosed is a report of forty three thousand
absentee ballot votes counted. Now the counted
is capitalized. Guys, the counting is so important
that he's put a capital C on it in the middle of
a sentence. Absentee ballots of ballot votes
counted in DeKalb County that violated the
chain of custody rules, making them invalid. I
would respectfully request that your department
check this. And if true, along with many other
claims of voter fraud and voter irregularities,
start the process of decertifying the election or
whatever the correct legal remedy is and announce
the true winner, he's saying announce me
as the winner of Georgia. It's October.
As stated to you previously, the number of false
and or irregular votes is far greater than needed
to change the Georgia election result. People
do not understand why you and Gov.. Brian Kemp
adamantly refuse to acknowledge the now proven
facts and fight so hard that the election truth
not be told, you and Governor Kemp are doing a
tremendous disservice to the great state capitals
of Georgia and to our capital and nation, which is
systematically being destroyed by an illegitimate
president and his administration. The truth
must be allowed to come out. Thank you for your
attention to this matter. Their argument is that
because some forms were dated a few hours late,
I'm interpreting what is being said here. OK, some
forms were dated a few hours late. They want every
result from all of those ballot boxes thrown out
and not counted. They want to disenfranchize tens
of thousands of voters because of some messed up
paperwork with some of these ballots. Now, the law
that they cite is this emergency declaration,
which has rules for ballot drop boxes.
It doesn't say if any rule is valid, violated.
You throw the all the ballots in the box into the
trash. It doesn't actually say that. It doesn't
say throw the votes out and don't count them. So
all of this is being signal boosted by
articles being written that say because
it appears that maybe some ballots had
were a few hours late in being certified,
you need to just throw out all the ballots from
those ballot boxes. There's nothing in the law
that suggests that that should be happening. So
at this point, is this a mental health issue?
Is this trolling? Is it grifting? It was just this
letter was released just before the Saturday rally
in support of the Trump writers. Maybe it was an
indirect way to try to rile people up. Remember
Donald Trump? Remember when he just asked for
eleven thousand votes to be found for him?
Speaker 2: I need 11000 votes. Give me a break.
Speaker 1: This guy seems willing to do anything.
But again, the issue is the burden of proof.
He says he has the evidence, but he wants Brad
Raffensperger to prove that his allegations are
true. What this may actually be is an attempt
to preempt what increasingly seem. Like is going
to be an investigation into Trump's attempts to
overturn the Georgia results. This is an article
from Friday, the same day as this letter came out.
Georgia criminal probe into Trump's attempts to
overturn 20 20 election quietly moves forward,
quietly moves forward. So this may be Trump trying
to argue, look, I wasn't trying to break the law
when I asked for eleven thousand votes. What I
meant is what I said in this letter, which is you
should investigate this and you should investigate
that. It's kind of like that weasely Mafioso type
speak that we've become accustomed to from Donald
Trump. But a delusional letter. I was convinced
this letter must be six months old. No, it's
from Friday and we will continue to follow it.